my name is andrés feaps 0 i work on
that i am a machine learning engineer i
am in most of the people who
come to present
this conference i come more from the
engineering background and i approach
data science and amazon mine to  starting from
working on back end systems and big
data mainly so I will go to when I
can enrich the notions that
I expressed with my experience in that in that
area let's say well let's start let's
start
the talk is about
automatic suggestions in conversational systems
obviously today we are going to present  the
problem was a little bit of notions
so that the context in
which we want to apply it is well understood and what kind of
problems we solve in our company
later I will show some
background on the subject how it is
normally solved what options are there
the pros and cons things  like that and
at the end I'm going to describe a little bit of the
solution that we ended up implementing and
how that fits into our  another system and with
our non-official requirements,
well, the problem has basically been,
as you can see in the diagram,
imagine a conversation
we have two participants and one of the
participants we want to increase the one
that the milestone robot has, that
is, in this it is not such  it is a
more classic problem the machine
learning where we want to replace the
human being but in this case then
we increase we give him tools so
that during a conversation that the
person has to have he can
respond more quickly and efficiently
the conversations have a context that they
are  Basically, all the twists and turns
that the conversation has, the
messages that the client sent and the
messages that our people sent,
and it can also be enriched
by other things, but mainly by
the story, so in each situation
where people have to generate a
response to the client
we increase it as you say it
generates a  response suggestion and we
increase it by giving suggestions everything
still the human being has control
over what was done
well here of the particles inside the
problem of our problem is that the
agents collaborate with us they are
people from whom we can ask for
feedback they cannot say how it works
the system
we have all the record of everything it
does in the system like this a record at the
end as the positive area says
so we can save I have
information on all the history of
past conversations the moment
they happened what was adopted
and the  suggestions obviously you have
regenerated online
no no maybe it is more difficult to put
a strong restriction on real time
but it has to be a reasonable time
so that
the conversation is not affected because
if every time our agent has to
answer they have to wait a
considerable time communication is hampered
well normally to the discipline that
encompasses  ba to our problem it is called
as the generation of controlled text
that name is not so common but
but it appears like this in various parts of the
literature especially it is used in
chat bots that others in other parts of
our system use it but it is not the
case in the example I am showing today and
now we are also going to move on to one of the
solutions it is classic that problem is
rule-based models
general generative models and lastly what
is the solution we have implementing
the tribal models
I as an engineer yes  method that
this problem presents to
me today I am already more internalized
with the machine learning tools
I am also going to want to see let's go to a
model with 800 layers all like this but
first what would I think about your rule model
synthesize
a sequence of tips or  a dictionary
of rules and in which I go
one by one to a message to see if there is
any that backpack and decide what to
say what is the answer  what has
to be given
is all very good the meme that carelessness
is unmasked has been evaluated and there is the little
tree ganis
and then as I said there is a list
of rules the criterion is a criterion
with which the text sequence more already with
those rules than  Well, sometimes it can be
as simple as I said, it was not done, it is
possible, then, to have to make a model,
although when the model that has
to be in that case grows a lot,
one begins to think of other
alternatives as a mark of the problem
based on the rules that are applied,
simple enterprise templates are used to
generate responses and we say
simple because they just consume the
context in a very basic way, they
simply have some pet
holders that have to be filled in to
generate the response and nothing else
good like  you can imagine all the
methods have their pros and cons in
this case this one is very simple
which is very good because one cannot
only produce very quickly  do and have
immediate feedback that I find very, very
interesting, especially when you have
data to base yourself on to
train a slightly more
sophisticated model, so you see, it's very
good, and put on a profession quickly, have it,
follow quickly, and be able to act
Consequently,
another issue that they fix that they manage well
is
this problem vessel is that
you are not going to get surprises and you are not going to
have cases, for example of
sensitive cases that you should handle well and not make
mistakes that is not going to happen with the
rules no  you're going to have no surprises
it's going to behave exactly as you
program this the rules for them to come out
then you're not going to have a
complicated situation where there's something you
shouldn't have said or where you should
know you should have expressed yourself differently
but but in return
the  response generated are others
yes
in this case there is a there is a human what we
have we are a situation of human
in the lo  op then the people are going to
serve as the last bastion so that the
conversation remains good but if
we only suggest things in a very
monotonous way they will not have a choice as they do not
have good options
at the time of having to use them they will
not decide not to use the  system and it is
precisely what we want to avoid,
that is why perhaps one moves to a
more modern and traditional approach,
today we
have, we have neural models that allow us to
process sequences that condense all
the information, a sequence in a
vector, and from that we can
we can generate the response that would come
that the response that people may
end up choosing to continue the
conversation so
in this example let's say we have a
recurrent neural network the stm one time
directional system or whatever
else it takes you today
that processes stopped sentences  per
word and in this way they accumulate
the information they find in a
vector,
this vector that  In general, it could be
considered an mbe ding of the input, that is to
say that we are mapping the input of
variable length to a vector space
where the length of the vector is known
and therefore more manageable
later to
generate the possible answers this
side of the other half of  the network that uses
as first input precisely this vector
of measurement that was generated before
and the system generates each of
the possible words one by one using
auto regressive using the cut hair of the
initial step, that is,
when the unit of a unit  it has to
generate a next word it is fed
with the previous word that was generated
again we find that the
approaches have pros and cons in this
case this approach generalizes very well it is going
to be able to process any in any
input
that is offered something that  I forgot to
say in the previous case it is that I do not
handle the inputs but in this
case for any input to generate
a response
the topic  The answer is no,
especially considering that it is
possible to generate an observation to be
found with sentences that have
never been seen before, so it is very difficult to
predict or have confidence that it
will make any sense,
what also happens is  that the
properties that we want the
operator to have are very difficult to tune
if it is very difficult
this is very difficult
let's say map in the parameters that one
can feel a euro nal rule in
conversational properties that have
the responses generated
and well and so let's continue
to
and the other way of thinking of the problem
which is to think of it as a retrib problem
the idea is that we can think of the
different possible answers
produced that we have as documents and
we have to pull those
documents out like one would in a
lucid type search system  elastic search and
offer that ranked response to the
user
as this solution told him that
we ended up implementing as
We have a little more experience in
how to tune it in our cases we
find
that although we have a lot of
control over the answers that can
be given and these are varied with
the agents what also ends up
happening is that there are many
many answers  that they are redundant
that basically say the same thing in another
way so what we do is one thing that
I am going to explain later that we
do is to cluster
the predefined answers that
we have in different ways to precisely find a little
more diversity in the answers
once  that we have the possible
answers generated what we are going to do
is with a machine learning model
order them apply a score to them that is to say
we have all of them now we are going to see more
in detail but we have all the
possible answers we have the input
we calculate a score all with all with
all  and the solana mos for the sector
in this case I am going to explain the pros
and cons before  Before I go into more
detail, this article fits a lot with the
idea of ​​having a person, a person in
the middle, there is an image of light precisely
because it is based on the
withdrawal system, from the start they were designed
so that someone can make queries to
a  system and a human evaluate them
as we control together
with the agents that are part of
we can consider part of our
team for this case
we can define a priori all the
conversational characteristics that
have that response in this case
we have in the examples no quality
fluency
fluency  they can not think of it in
contrast to what a generative model would perhaps generate,
which is that it can
become that it can be obvious
that it is not written by a person or in
the case of simple rules the
first example  that it is not so monotonous
that there is a let's say how to say it a
harmony in what is said and the other issue
that we make sure is that there is
diversity  in the answers is that to
compare an example perhaps an agent
of our people does not want to
directly answer the question if he
does not want to ask for more information or
something like that and that is good that the
system then passes and also in this
type of models
or better said tribal model what it
has is how it is well studied and
has been has and has been implemented
for a long time they already come they already have a
form that allows them to have good
non-functional properties as they are
easy the easier it is to debug  they are easier
to optimize as far as we would say at
computation time and in our case what I am going
to show now the model we
built was
we built many times we took into
account being able to respond quickly to
reach the constraint that we named at the
beginning that it has to  be online a
response
to start with we are a
post-war to be integration
called fas text
the idea of ​​fast text is not only to
generate in v  ending to prepare itself
but to generate in venice for all the
entities grams of the words in theory
in theory it could be for all in
grams but the pp one of the
original papers really recommends that
you do between 3 and 6 and keep the
original word  and that's it
this improves performance when
words are misspelled for example
then it makes it more robust spelling errors
and another thing is that it also ends up
working quite well with
words it makes the models work
quite well with unknown words
if one studies  the law of whether it will be remembered
that there are, let's say with parameters 0.5, the
halves of the vocabulary words
appear only once in a corpus,
then we will find several
cases where using fast text will improve
the person, for example, in Spanish there are
many words that  although one cannot
know meaning from its structure or
from its ending, one can know
what kind of word it is from.  Let's talk and in
this case this method explodes
well and now if the neural drawing
on the outside they were finally waiting for it
[Music]
we had it implemented like this let's say
this is a
ritual mariana it's not a strong table why
the two subnets don't share no
they share weights each one
learns its own weights so
once it is evaluated in the two
networks each part of the
from the larger network that underlines it goes
back general
as if everything today on the
left side is the context that  This is
basically the history of the
conversations that happened previously
and, on the other hand, of the possible
answers that I already have, the list
generated well, a similarity score is generated using
the scalar product of the kitchen distance,
basically, and with that
the possible answers are started
you can see at the bottom the input
of the two
the two sequences are framed
as castex
each of the words is replaced
by elector  corresponding fax fas text
yes that is fed to
a network to a recurring radio that in
this case was using that
serious virus to a modification on the
units the stm that makes them much
simpler rather more perform
before in terms of the need  of
computation and make its calculation
predictable they
lower the complexity a little the
capacity of the unit that is, they can
learn less complex
functions than one the stm could
learn what is good about them is that
they are what you talk about let's say no  they have the
limitation that the stm has when
a piece uses many many units
learning becomes complicated in the
case of these they can be stacked I have seen
paper that show up to 10 and there
is no problem
and after after
the incode and that  they generate what the
recurrent network generates,
paul becomes and how special his attention is going to be,
now I am going to explain a
little more and with that it ends great
n  we are in beige
one thing that is very good with this
model that makes the function
separable, that is, it has two large
parts two large parts joined by
joined by a product is that the part
of the answers can be computed do not
leave it necessary to compute  the two
parts at the same time so I can
have all
the response vectors precomputed and simply
when predicting evaluate the
left network on the input and it will be the
scalar product on the two on the
two in beijing generated one that  It
was already presented that it is an operation
once, computationally, it is very
light, so I simply have
to make sure to evaluate the
left network and, as we said before,
because of how this virus works, it
is very easy to do that calculation
if you want to know more or if you want to  know
more there was
the art
with the reference
this model was published by the people
to be made in this company so
there you can see all  two the details if you
are more interested
now I am going to explain a little more
what this being fa tension is because
the idea is to enrich the mbe
dyn vector that we have this case of fast text
with information that the
other words provide me  of the sentence in will
react to the word a
particular word nothing was seen I am going to
testify the most now
imagine a sentence where one of the
words refers to another for
example
a good example could be the dog that
crossed the street and fell who
the dog fell then it would be nice if it
fell grab some of the
dog's information and so when it is processed
the algorithm will take that information into account
and look for more relationships with
other words the trapped relationship no
if it's not like the  weight of the other
words with which it is related
will be added to and
and it will behave more similarly to the
words to which it refers
may seem complicated but the model
in def  initiva is again multiplying
by matrices in this case three additional matrix matrices are used
to calculate for each
word three modes of three vectors a
vector that we call query increased the
samu skin and a vector that we call value
what are we going to do we are going to do a
kind of template plus temple and machine
between the query of each of a word and
the scj and of all the other words
with a simple scalar product which
cannot start as a projection
of the query vectors of each
word in the sectors  What about the other
words
is that projection is going to give me a score
that I don't show but it will even be
normalized by soft max, that is,
again linear matrices and soft max
and with those coefficients
that represent how much the
word refers to  so marked from the other
, the valium vectors of the words are going to be weighed,
that is, I think of it a bit
as a kind of base change in a
vector space, not because it is one of the
projections and then the
vectors of the other base are added, it is not so
because as you can see the
scalar product is made between
different vectors but that symmetry is necessary
because if not what ends up if that were
not asymmetric what ends up happening
is that all  the reference words
would always do themselves and that's just
not what we want
and the only change to this that we made
in our model is that we use what's
called multijet ser for tension which
is basically having many readers
may and many key authors and many
sectors value
and applied at the same time and then
all this is joined multiplied by a
matrix so that the algorithm can
find these relationships in various
positions and between various words otherwise
this will favor some words
over others
well the cartoon disappeared twenty
times in  these legs
as I said before we have a lot of
predefined responses and what we
generate are called candid  atas because they are
candidates because the bootstrapping algorithm is
going to boot them and it is going to
grab a top of those of those
ranked candidates because I cannot
show all the ones we have to the user
loc
a criterion that we could have to
choose the candidates is only by
frequency by  1 that's good
because the options that
religion users most often
are really good
10 - spelling error is so well
written etc. but what ends up
happening is that you end up having a lot of
redundancy with the answers and here
remember it's something we wanted to avoid
so we have  some
casting schemes that help us solve this
one is putting this is using the
vending that generates the right subnet
we can characterize that you can do
it could not be worse and let's say it is not
necessary to do it at the time of making
the prediction or also in some  cases
we have tried some simple
post run clustering scheme that or we
simply say yes in  then
[Music]
if two answers have the same
score or a very similar score,
let's say the best one because we
get that the other is quite
similar and up to a certain delta this is an
opportunity due to triangular inequality it
works
well
as this is a thoughtful talk  its
archive moment
from top to bottom we have we are
building an
artificial intelligence framework called frank
see if they go half a point and you can
see it we use it to build our
models not all of them yet but I plan to
pass everything to flash me what flanders has very
cool  that it
is a good manager the infrastructure
raises the new ones in our case in
amazon but it is evaluated it searches you
by parameters it is good in your in we are
very happy with the one that
my colleagues built it is quite new that
is why I tell his colleagues and we will  to
end up using for all our
models and well finally we are
hiring
[Applause]
hello good  s afternoons first thank you very
good talks I had the same
experience implement something very similar
type almost the same dance almost everything is the same
in me in my work with a
slightly different problem I wanted to ask you
why you have to make the product in the
end it has a  wave I don't know if you've
run into héctor timerman hat in the
stm there is another one who uses it, he gets hurt and several
things and what I found is that
because of the private domain I
didn't like any of these who
usually hang out with him  to the ubuntu cdc the
most good but well important the
question is that I wanted to ask because
what I found that changed a lot
was to change the termination at the end
let's say by putting something other than
the product the product the product to
scale I wanted to know if  you tried something
else in the end because there are some papers
that make a difference after the proxy
in this case did not leave you alone but I had the
experience of having used distance ucr
and target and it worked  to perfect and with the
scalar product for nothing has happened to me
in this case
and